pour barry blocage le menabe maintenant
vous dis comme ça me fout là dans
d'autres cas oui et non oui non que oui
ce soir c'est la vie tous à vos claviers
patrice ménon plein dans l'anniversaire
judy comme ça ou non ça nous sort comme
ça on connaît bien commun d'idées un
dernier coup est bien écrit pas à mourir
ou connais bien comportée même et lycées
sans même que des goûts il est bon à
rien
j'ai papa aussi embrassades y aussi les
paroles et la wii par an les la rive
représente la dit non par contre là où
les là une apprentie garçon est bien
voir par quoi
non non non non non à des questions
elle est bien l biens à cause de ces
fous pas mal à la paix pully les la
casse ont complété des passes on combine
là mais il y avait de tout notre poids
ce que ça même quand c'est mon enfant
nous la responsabilité sur quoi le peak
oil ça rentre laquelle bell vendredi à
jamais parce que tu as c'est mon film
verrait scène comme moi et comme son
papa aussi un qui s'est dit au cou
l'essonne qui sont idéaux vous
n'approuvez pas moins un conseiller du
col de l'utérus à tous peu ou mal
fidèles et en plus mal amoureuse je suis
moins schéma moureu chéri
amoureux ou pas fidèle au pas fait
d'elle le virus qui donne le cancer du
col de l'utérus banier pas à tous les
atouts oui en plus lisse sexuellement
transmissibles non mais attends un virus
est de ne conserver
sexuellement
ou de vrais emmène puis fait le vaccin
comme ça avant que li nina relations
sexuelles protégées fait dans son vaccin
wimax un pack vaccin
oui mais il prend un peu le concert pour
guérir qu'on sait où sauf une vie ça ou
c'est comme si on dirait en ce qu'on
dirait un moune de fait la preuve de ses
dix mille fois vous le fait décider pour
guérir les non mais attends
important
expliquant
juste pour expliquer ou comme ça le fait
que ça va à la plage oui vous fait pour
protéger les vies humaines et la crème
dessus mahomet notamment sur l'est ou de
la crème oui le vaccin n'est pareil
c'est pour protéger deux camps ou
pourboire en plus vite dix ans il
utilise ça mais me conseilla ollier
fiables voire de confiance baisser
ribeiro des vaccins pour moi
à oui lèverait
way up
tv
les
verts
maman est ce que cela finit geyson
l'invitation z cela peut encore des
rescapés dans cette boîte aux lettres
bientôt zotti gaye sarr bonjour docteur
de rechange ça va bien très bien vous ça
va merci est ce que nous explique amour
une dépistage c'est quoi alors one
dépistage est une association est
financé par le ministère de la santé la
sécurité sociale et qui a pour but de
valoriser le dépistage organisé est de
faire reculer le cancer qu'est le cancer
en particulier alors trois cancers on a
commencé par le cancer du sein
s'appelait avant mamou ron ensuite le
cancer du côlon et le cancer plus
récemment du col de l'utérus et beaucoup
et rien que ces trois conseillères là
parce que c'est les cancers qui évolue
lentement et c'est des cancers qui sont
fréquents 1 le cancer du côlon est
fréquent chez l'homme et la femme
surtout à partir de 50 ans le cancer du
sein c'est le cancer le plus fréquent
chez la femme et cancer du col de
l'utérus est un cancer qui
malheureusement est encore fréquent sur
l'île de rhinau et faire un dépistage la
croyance erne alors sa soeur à dépister
des lésions un stade précoce qui sont
peut-être même pas encore cancéreuses
pré cancéreuse et qui vont permettre un
traitement plus efficace et moins lourd
donc la 2me niveau soir à ce courriel à
la casse c'est quoi cette lettre alors
grâce au fichier de sécurité social on
peut envoyer aux personnes concernées
une invitation à se faire dépister donc
nous reçoit le croyez nous prend rendez
vous c'est quoi les différentes étapes
alors par exemple pour le cancer du sein
on va recevoir l'invitation avec la
liste les radiologues qui sont agréés on
va prendre rendez vous chez le
radiologue le radiologue va examiner la
personne a examiné les seins il va faire
une mammographie et cette mammographie
cd normale sera envoyé un dépistage elle
sera lue par un 2ème radio l'année ils
servent à quelque chose de faire relire
sa part une magistrature des chiffres on
trouve à peu près une 120 cancer par an
grâce au dépistage du organiser et à peu
près neuf cancers sont trouvés par la
deuxième lecture ah oui quand même et
pour le cancer du col de l'utérus
commence à lens un cancer du col de
l'utérus on invite les femmes
réaliser un frottis tous les 3 ans les
femmes de 25 à 65 ans et pour les
cancers du côlon et pour le cancer du
côlon l'invitation propose aux personnes
d'aller voir son médecin traitant qui va
nous juger s'il est nécessaire ou non de
faire un dépistage et remettent un test
hémoccult à faire à la maison alors
manuel diaz est que les dépistages les
gratuits apparemment les fascine et puis
les plus que nécessaire on peut
rapporter gros ce qui sauve des vies
quand même un cancer que les prix à
temps il peut être guéri et puis c'est
un acte d'amour posé de bonnes proche de
famille qu ensemble l'est de l'état où
je me dis rien à fait accepte
l'invitation